I'm Trevor Phillips this is Common
Ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation
tonight's end with some flash
photography parts of our mini budget
went further and faster the markets were
expecting
so the way we are delivering our mission
right now has to change growth requires
confidence and stability and the United
Kingdom will always pay its way that we
need to do more more quickly to give
certainty to the markets about our
fiscal plans markets are asking serious
questions about our commitment to sound
public finances it was both Frank and
bold and it appears in the very short
term that these two have steadied the
markets there will be great relief
across the house that the markets have
responded positively to my right
honorable friends statement economic
policy has been made with primarily the
markets in mind today has been an
extremely difficult and turbulent day
massive speculative flows continue to
disrupt the functioning of exchange rate
mechanism not since 1992 and black
Wednesday when the UK was thrown out of
the ERM if we had a moment quite like
that we need to act now to reassure the
markets of our fiscal discipline
always in power but never in office the
markets it seems are calling the tune
and our elected leaders are being
compelled to dance in time
covered and War have driven countries
all over the world to spend money they
haven't got the markets have filled the
gaps
some argue it was ever thus governments
have to come to terms with those who
risk lending them cash foreign
governments and speculators yes but also
their own citizens who put their money
into bonds and pensions they decide
where to put their own savings and it's
only fair that the greater the risk the
greater the reward
but others believe that democracies Dice
With the Devil if they rely too heavily
on borrowed money and that politicians
can end up paying over the odds and
worse surrendering too much power to
unelected and unaccountable financial
institutions
our choice tonight accept the markets as
a fact of life even if they limit what
democracies can do or call a halt and
pay the price in cuts and austerity in
the next 30 minutes we go in search of
common ground
[Music]
with me tonight the author and
journalist Owen Jones
the financial analyst Louise Cooper who
is senior lecturer in finance at
Kingston University business school and
to John Geeve the former deputy governor
of the bank of England
start by making sure that we're all
talking about the same thing now um I
haven't worked in financial markets nor
has Owen so let me start with you John
and Louise who or what are the people or
institutions that matter when we're
talking about stability of the markets
Louise
there are lots and lots of different
financial markets there's credit default
swaps there's options markets there's
all sorts of match markets the three we
really want to focus on is currency
markets particularly if the pound goes
down the big problem for us is we import
inflation inflation tomorrow expected to
be 10 bit problematic next Market is the
stock market the UK stock market's been
pretty poor for a very long time that
makes our companies cheap to buy from
overseas investors and it means if they
want to raise new money if companies
want to raise news money
um it's difficult for them to do do it
but the third and most important Market
I would say at the moment is the
government borrowing markets what we
call guilts and when a country has 2.4
trillion pounds of debt which is what we
have those borrowing costs can become
highly problematic exceedingly quickly
so there are loads of financial markets
and they pop up every now and again with
their Consciousness in is to what's
happening but the key one right now in a
world of increasing interest rates is
government borrowing markets globally
but our one is called guilts John do you
agree agree with that that actually
those are the the key ones and the one
we need to keep our eye on most are the
bond markets the uh lending to
government what when people talk about
10-year and 30 year yields that one yeah
it says to you and I'd put those ahead
of the stock market which goes up and
down and um uh isn't quite so critical
to maintaining uh stability
um as to who they are
um there are some uh spectacular figures
individuals who appear on the front
pages and do actually
move quite large sums of money but most
of the players are in institutions
they're salary people sitting in banks
of desks with the job of
um uh buying and selling currency buying
and selling bonds trying to make a
little bit better deals than the guy in
the desk next door or down the street
but these are meant to be sort of uh
really boring outfits aren't they
they're
better
this is meant to be the most boring kind
of place to put your money because
nobody takes a risk nobody ever gets
turned over or anything like that what
the heck happened
well two things happened firstly they've
become less boring right right with the
way across the world uh as inflation has
gone up and particularly in the west
we've seen interest rates starting to
climb and an intention to send them
higher in the United States this is a
big big change after 10 years when
interest rates were around zero it now
looks as though they're going to move up
to four or five percent worldwide so
that has been disruptive huge changes
are happening because of that and then
there was the UK problem which was that
we announced or seemed to announce that
we we weren't uh our government wasn't
much concerned about boring old stuff
about balancing the books that was just
treasury Orthodoxy they were going to do
something more radical and then they
followed that up with one side of a
budget the giveaways without really
making any attempt at all to explain how
they were going to pay for it oh and do
you you recognize this picture and
is it your your view that actually this
was a sort of tactical political mistake
or as a
a systemic systemic rottenness here of
course aesthetic I mean one Economist
put into me quite well that you should
regard the market it's like a dangerous
guard dog that you should uh you should
you should be very gentle don't make any
sort of movements uh keep eye contacts
no sudden surprises and and I think if
you if you look at what the government
did they sacked the relevant civil
servant Tom scholar the perm sector
absolutely they didn't go through the
office for Budget responsibility they
didn't provide
um you know in a sense What markets want
is predictability uh they want to know
what's going to happen in the medium and
long term uh they don't want any sudden
surprises now you know we can argue that
this was an assault on Democracy about
the markets but of course the problem
with that is this wasn't put actually in
a democratic Arena it wasn't put to the
British people in a general election it
actually wasn't even put to conservative
party members so it was a complete
surprise uh look thrown at the markets
with a promise that there would be uh
there would be forecasts uh several
months after uh the proposals had been
implemented but what I just think is
interesting because you mentioned the
the issue of course in debt if you
compare where we were when covert
happened uh where we had obviously a
vast sum of debt far more than we did in
2010 for example where austerity was
launched by uh David Cameron and George
Osborne but of course you didn't have a
sudden Financial economical Market
reaction to the vast sums of money that
was thrown quite rightly at keeping the
economy running uh during covid uh
because he obviously had a very
different context where he didn't have
inflation that sweeping Across the
Western World and then the expectation
of interest rate Rises which is what
obviously is is is is was already the
context which which this government uh
you know through this this bombshell
into the market so what we're missing
here is an explanation of what
quantitative easing is because we're
talking about the bond market the guilt
market and the power it has and there's
a fantastic quote actually for me um a
political advisor of Clinton who said
um
when I died I wanted to be reincarnated
as the president the pope or a you know
a big baseball hitter and he said
actually what I've now learned because
Clinton had his problems with the
markets what I've now learned is I want
to be reincarnated as the bond market
because then I can intimidate everybody
so it is true that the government
borrowing markets have huge power
because if they look at governments and
think they're being fiscally
irresponsible with Taxation and spending
they will say we're going to charge you
more money we're going to charge you a
higher interest rate but what is really
interesting about this debate is that
because of quantitative easing
Bond markets have not had that power for
15 years they have not in fact the most
powerful player in the bond market has
been sorry sir John to do this to you
has been the central banks also not
elected okay so the most powerful player
has been the central banks they have
controlled the world for 15 years but
that is now ending because in a world of
higher inflation in a world of interest
rates going up quantitative easing is
being reversed and it is that that has
really changed the dynamic because up to
now governments could spend spend spend
spend spend spend spend spend spend
spend does not matter because your
central bank would buy up all your debt
that's what QE is and it's that that is
now coming to an end and it is that that
is really changing the dynamic not that
we're pointing the finger here or
anything I'm just sort of pointing out
in this central banks but former deputy
governor of the bank of England
that's completely true I mean what's
happened is after years of of having the
uh monetary policy accelerator pressed
to the floor zero interest rates buying
all the guilts quantitative easing but
inflation very well behaved we've
finally seen inflation rise and much
faster than central banks
um had had allowed for and they and
they've reversed engines so that's
what's happening worldwide I think uh in
the British case
um we when we increase borrowing after
the financial crisis and when we
increase borrowing in kovid we did it
alongside everyone else everyone was
doing it it was a common International
problem and in a sense we didn't stand
out from the crowd I think what we did
in September was to really draw
everyone's attention to us this was
presented as a as a radical change of
policy that we were doing and no one
else was doing and that I think is a
very dangerous thing to do when you have
to borrow in international markets well
I just lose it before I come to William
I know you follow the international
markets a lot
are we unique in the situation that
we're in I would say we're the canary in
the mine I would say we're the first one
to be taken down
um the first one with the Bond
vigilantes what we as we call them like
the the people that lend us money that
enable us to spend beyond what we tax as
all governments love to do because we
all want more spending but nobody wants
to pay for it right that's what
governments do
um and we are the first to be attacked
but I'm telling you Italy massive debt
massive government debt in Italy new
political party highly problematic
roughly parity with GDP at the moment
we're way below Italy is highly popular
is above the CDP isn't it yeah so Italy
Dutch GDP is about 145 yeah the UK is
about 90. so Italy is the problem debt
child of Europe so I think we were the
first because as John explained the mini
Maxi budget but I do not think we will
be the last every government will be
grappling with
building up massive amounts of debt over
the last 15 years and now suddenly your
Central Bank ain't buying it so somebody
else you have to convince somebody else
to fund your excesses and that's what's
proving the problem because up to now
European Central Banker by Bank of
England to buy it Bank of Japan and buy
it Federal Reserve will buy it everybody
will buy up now that's not happening I
just thought it's just going about the
financial crisis because of course this
has all been used now to essentially say
well look this is a Vindication of the
austerity policy pursued by George
Osborne and David Cameron's government I
mean we've got this program's called
Common Ground I do have common ground it
turns out with Liz truss and quasi
quartet who's rhetoric very well just
stop there and
Owen Joan common ground with literally
yeah
um
no because what they accept was
austerity had failed I mean they they
made she was talking about Decades of
stagnant and economic growth and
actually from the 80s onwards we've had
much lower average and economic growth
than for the rest of the post war that
period and and but but she was
essentially doing a critique of
austerity and and she committed to not
returning to those policies but but the
if you go back to what happened after
the financial crash what was so tragic
about you know the argument then that
the bond markets would discipline a
government which attempt which didn't
which didn't do austerity but of course
borrowing costs were very low at that
period I mean the tragedy is that we
could have borrowed to invest and we
didn't in that period
um and the argument was if you didn't
then the Credit Agencies would strip
Britain of its credit rating and
therefore government borrowing would
surge well that happened in 2013 anyway
during austerity our AAA rating was
taken away did government borrowing
costs go up no they did not there wasn't
a Revolt of the bond market so I just
think it's really important that we
don't end up because I know this is
what's been used at the moment to
justify the policy of austerity which
took place after 2010 on the grounds
that this would have happened if George
Osborne hadn't done that because it
wouldn't have happened I want to come
back to the that point in a moment but
let's go to the sort of this a central
question really which is the relative
power of the market and we don't need to
think about it as conspiracy this is we
as we've heard uh it's all our savings
we are expect our Pension funds to get
the best out for us but have we
unwittingly walked into a situation
where in a sense
these markets have power over
democracies our democracy particularly
by limiting the options that government
have the last two generations elected
governments have abdicated their
responsibilities to the market that's
what the policies of deregulation and
privatization have actively sought to do
where governments as a consequence
basically pre as As a matter of virtue
praised the idea that they are no longer
responsible for large sections of the
economy and society and that the market
instead will provide all that's why we
privatize basic utilities on the basis
that energy would be better best
provided for example by the private
sector didn't turn out that way or water
that you would get suddenly water
companies able to get all the access to
private Capital never happened uh that
they that they would they would better
invest in their services didn't happen
but governments could wash the hands of
these things and say not our problem gov
nothing to do with us the market now is
in charge of providing these functions I
would argue that obviously has been a
disaster I mean other arguments you
could say is you know Capital controls I
suppose I mean okay let me let me just
tell us John whether whether you record
recognize that picture of the
relationship between the market and our
governments in the well let's say since
2010
um
oh I recognize the attack uh I I I I
don't buy it I mean I think governments
are held responsible actually for the
prosperity of the people and the success
of the economy and when
um so if you like the the the move to
regulated markets rather than public
utilities was taken on the basis so that
would improve our economic performance
which it did relatively for up until the
financial crisis we've absolutely
yeah but we've had a a really bad 10
years in terms of productivity and
growth that's absolutely true
um partly that would have been to do
with the austerity policies but also I
think there have been other more
profound reasons for it we we have
um we haven't had good training policies
and education policies research
development planning
we appear to have done a bit better on R
D than we thought but yes absolutely uh
private sector investment and public
sector investment have been very low and
that so
I think when you're dealing with
productivity and growth you've got to
look at it almost a decade at a time
that was one of the difficulties about
the mini budget was saying this is all
about growth but you know growth in five
years time I mean what they were
promising was cash tomorrow for growth
in five years time and that that didn't
quite add up I don't want to take us too
far onto what um people these days
called Supply the supply supply side
questions because that's in a way
slightly different I just want to stick
for the moment with the extent to which
we're in a different situation than we
have in the past where consideration and
stability of the market has been a
factor for governments
compared to what appears to have been
the situation in the last 10 days or so
where it has become the objective of
policy for governments I mean to a
certain extent if you don't build up the
debt you're not
you know you're not you know at the
exposure I mean that's the brutal
reality if you don't have huge amounts
of debt then it doesn't matter but if
you have
built up enormous quantities of debt
which is what we have done since the
global financial crisis I keep saying
500 billion of national debt pre the
global financial crisis 2.4 trillion now
so if we didn't have 2.4 trillion debt
we would be less exposed to the
financial markets but the key thing the
key key thing is that quantitative
easing has changed it now a lot of
people don't understand QE but
essentially the government's issue debt
guilts in the UK or those other words
you know treasury Bonds in America or
booms in Germany or whatever you want to
call oats in you know and and they issue
debt and normally if you tax less than
you spend you somebody has to fund it in
the last 15 years one part of government
has issued the debt the other part a
separate your central bank has brought
it all up you have not needed to
persuade anybody right the central bank
is the power in the room nobody nobody
in the markets ever ever ever
takes the opposing view to the spiritual
back because the central bank is the
most powerful player now that Central
Bank has it's not there anymore and
suddenly you've got to convince somebody
will you fund us well thanks Andrew
that's the problem as Andrew Bailey said
last week to that to everybody uh we're
going to buy some of this debt but
actually on Friday it all stops I think
that's that that call the hall oh and um
in a way isn't this a sort of not
natural outcome of very exceptional
circumstances uh covid
huge amounts of public spending and uh
the war in Ukraine and that actually at
some point as it were normal service
will be will be resumed and the
relationship between the politicians and
the money men will be under control from
the point of view of the Democracy well
I mean all Western European nations have
had to deal with those exact same
problems it's us who uniquely suffered
the crisis that we had I know you said
with the canary in the mind but I mean
look we are clearly the outlier as
things stand in terms of what's just
happened I mean there was a CR look you
know from a leftist perspective you can
almost uh you know you think somebody
myself would say well sod the markets
you know you should just do exactly what
what you want to do in my case it would
obviously have not been huge tax cuts
for rich people it would have been
investment in public services it would
be public ownership things like that but
you know what you know a clever
left-wing argument would be to accept
well actually we shouldn't have the
world in which we we live in in which
markets have been handed far too much
control we should have done what Norway
did when they had North Sea oil a bit of
solving wealth fund for example
Singapore is often looked at by
libertarian and economic and and
libertarian economic supporters but they
have huge State intervention in the
economy and the state-owned Enterprises
which actually intervene to invest in
things we haven't done that so what you
know John McDonald for example the
shadow Chancellor you know former
Charlie chances of labor definitely not
the charity chance of any more you know
a lot of what he did was completely
drowned out the noise in terms of that
whole Corbin period because his view was
if you want to do radical things you
can't surprise the markets so that's why
they try to set out in great detail what
they would do they went on a prawn
cocktail offensive
um in the city they tried to talk to
financiers on a daily basis and they
came up with a fiscal rule for example
which was you would only borrow to
invest you wouldn't borrow for anything
else so actually what they were trying
to do is say well look this isn't the
world we would have designed the markets
do have far much control but that
doesn't mean you can't have a radical
transformative government that does
things in the economy which a lot of
those investors won't like but as long
as they're offered reassurance as long
as they're offered long-term stability
then they won't take fright this
government didn't do that this
government just surprised that it just
went boo to a very angry dog which then
bit it oh I hope you won't mind me
saying this but that sounds like a
preposterously Blair right prospectus
and I don't I don't think Blair would
stop the nationalizing things and
impacting the rich in the sense in the
sense that what you're we do have some
common ground here which is that
actually there is a place for markets
but actually you have to get the
relationship right and I just want to
spend our last few minutes talking about
what what is the right relationship here
John I mean what let's assume that we're
in for as losers saying quite long
period inflation we're not going to be
able to run down this debt very easily
and therefore there's going to have to
be a clear relationship between those
who we've borrowed from and and the
state now
how do you manage that relationship in a
way that means that governments aren't
constantly looking over their shoulders
at you know traders in in Hong in Hong
Kong and what gives them the Jitters and
so on
well I was in the treasury for many many
years and we never stopped worrying
about what Traders were going to do
because they could blow us out of the
water as they did in the ERM as they did
in the 70s and as they've done again
right now you've got to see we we have
to live in the world as it exists the
markets are a constraint on what you can
do and the way you know which successive
governments have dealt with that is to
set out their version of John McDonald
the medium-term plan why actually we can
afford this over a period of years and
that we're not gonna we're not going to
bust the bank and
um you know you can imagine that if
um Rishi sunak had won the leadership
election he wouldn't have had a
statement in September he would be
sweating right now on what to say in his
in his half yearly budget in November
trying to make the numbers add up but he
would as his predecessor had done set it
in a medium term
context in which he says look we are
borrowing a hell of a lot for the energy
price uh guarantee for example in the
next six months 18 months but it's all
right look I can show you that this is
Affordable in the medium term so that's
the point of these fiscal rules
medium-term plans and so on and you've
got to have them because because it
markets are a fact of life Chancellor
Louise what what would you be doing this
week
hahaha
I'd probably fire my prime minister can
you do you have a prime minister so
you'd find Jeremy so
so this is the problem right so the
grown-up appeared he calmed everything
down I he he
but from a financial Market perspective
that's been great
but it hasn't really gone very far in
terms of the risk premium for UK assets
um the extra additional interest rate
the government has to pay because of our
perceived
uncertainty risk who the hell knows
what's going on in UK politics and what
somebody unkind is called the yeah the
[ __ ] [ __ ] premium risk great on the
more on premium risk and I'm afraid
that's still there that's still there in
all Sterling assets and the most
important one it's there for is in our
borrowing costs okay
um and the fact that it's in our
borrowing costs it was a Bloomberg
economics analysis suggesting it's going
to cost us 10 billion pounds a year for
every year that we have that premium
because of what's happened in the last
three to four weeks now 10 billion
pounds buys you a lot what what uh Han
was trying to do and why he had this
sort of many many four taste was
actually to try and reduce the rate of
interest you had to assume in his
forward projections and narrow that to
10 from 20 you know and what she's done
but it's not gone but it's not gone oh
and you're you're a special advisor I'm
special climbing I think it might be
Supreme dictate yeah that's a single
Market see how the markets respond to
that no um I think what's been missing
in this actually is quite an interesting
detail because the tragedy is now that
boring costs are higher and I think that
makes the argument ever stronger for
taxing those who have wealth and to
increase income tax and to increase
corporation tax and what's interesting
about what's just happened is
a semiotypical argument against
left-wing ideas or economic ideas would
be that if you seek to increase taxes on
those who have
businesses or all those wealth you'll
scare the markets but what scared of the
market is this time wasn't the idea of
increasing taxes on big business it was
actually the idea of not increasing
taxes on big business so the argument
there is made very very clearly for a
increase in taxes on those who actually
have a huge amount of money we created
record numbers of billionaires for
example during the covert pandemic given
given Corporation if if they had to live
increased corporation tax or they
haven't reversed their decision not to
to increase Corporation attacks then the
markets clearly were going to strangle
the British economy so obviously the
case now giving boring costs have gone
up is they've got to apply that
principle more broadly okay
well we have a remarkable level of
agreement here there's a place for the
market uh there is a relationship I
don't want it there is a relay that in
the real world there's a place for
Market that there is a a relationship
between governments and markets which
can be successful and actually it's not
too difficult to see exactly what that
is at the heart of it is certainty even
if you don't necessarily agree and I
think what one of the things that hasn't
been specifically said but I take from
this discussion is that we think of
markets we should think of markets not
as moral actors but as driven by
particular imperatives and they don't
have the markets don't have opinions
about what should happen but you need to
anticipate what they might or might not
do in a smart way
more to talk about I'm sure we're going
to be returning to this thank you all
three of you very much thank you for
watching stay with us we'll have all of
today's news coming up after the break
[Music]